Katy Perry is living her best life the  32 year old spent the weekend seemingly  enjoying everything that Italy's Amalfi  Coast has to offer Katy was photographed  sporting a colorful striped bikini and  adidas slides as she strolled near the  crystal-clear water and check out this  snap of her jumping off a cliff it's  pretty clear she has no fear  [Music]  Katie later instagrams this glam shot of  herself lounging in Capri writing  charging up before I light up  [Music]  the pop star has been jetting around  Europe last week she turned heads and  France at Paris oak Couture of Fashion  Week  Katy rocked a Corky space themed outfit  as she posed with a-list stars including  Cara Delevingne  Karl Lagerfeld and Claudia Schiffer  [Music]